dieser Döner ist aus dem wahrscheinlich
gehyptesten Dönerladen Kölns Holle war
schon hier abugoku war schon hier wir
werden diesen Döner und zwei weitere
Spots in diesem Video testen viel Spaß
mit dem Video los geht's mit dem
Döner lass weg das war der thbil Döner
und hinter mir seht ihr auch schon den
ersten Spot der gehypteste Dönerladen in
Köln aktuell keine Frage tasty ist der
Name alles daran erinnert eigentlich
gerade nicht an Dönerladen deshalb ist
er umso interessanter und ich bin
gespannt ob ich mir hier meinen
traumdöner zusammenbauen kann gehen wir
mal
rein
[Musik]
ich war wir noch nicht hier extra wegen
diesem Video auch mal ausprobieren die
anderen haben alle geschwärmt müssen
auch mal vorbeischauen ihr habt
Knoblauchsoße ne die vermisse ich sonst
hier in Köln ich würde glaube ich einen
Classic Döner nehmen ich würde ein
hähnchendöner nehmen mit Knoblauchsoße
alles außer Jalapenos und Zwiebeln alles
andere ja wir verschaffen uns jetzt
erstmal einen ganz ruhigen Überblick
über die Karte also im Lokal essen wir
sehen es gibt Döner es gibt Burger und
Panini es gibt se es gibt Pommes Döner
Düren fast schmein ein und ansonsten
gibt sogar Kaffee und andere Geschichten
also wir sind im Prinzip in dem Fastfood
dönerkonzept es erinnert sehr stark an
McDonald's an KFC und das ergibt ja auch
Sinn weil ich habe bei Holle gelernt
dass dieser Laden hier eröffnet wurde
vom KFC Chef Deutschland oder ehemaligen
besser gesagt deshalb interessiert mich
natürlich vor allem aber der Döner tasty
one Burger tasty one Burger das sind
einfach Burger mit Dönerfleisch auch
krank eigentlich sehr krass ja und dann
noch wie auf dem Cheeseburger auch so
ein paar Gewürzgurken drauf und so dann
lass uns auf jeden Fall tasty one nehmen
oder da haben wir drauf Döner Burger
saftiges Dönerfleisch von Rind
geschmolzener Cheddar würzige Burger
Gurken eisb Tomate crunchy onions und
ein Kombi aus warmer Cheddar und
burgersoße Soße auf dem Burger es klingt
krass aber ich weiß auch nicht ob es nur
gut klingt wir bestellen es trotzdem ja
wenn wir jetzt den anderen Döner noch
haben ist es eigentlich perfekt oder
weil was ist auf dem Classic Döner
chicken drauf sei einfach gut sei wie in
Berlin da bin ich zufrieden dann kann
ich wieder irgendwo hingehen Haus des
Döners hatte ich nämlich auch gesagt
dass ich das gut fand die haben nämlich
auch eine Knoblauchsoße wie in Berlin
aber Haus des Döners ist wirklich an
einem Tag gut und an neuen richtig
schlecht joghurtsße mit Reis das komisch
oder bestellen mal testen warum nicht es
wird wahrscheinlich ganz normaler Reis
sein ne die machen bestimmt irgendwas
besonderes Bestellung hinzufügen ein
Burger zwei verschiedene
[Musik]
Döner
ich bin sehr sehr sehr gespannt was uns
jetzt erwartet ich habe rausgehört bei
Holle dass er das richtig gut fand hier
und ich meine das will was heißen wenn
Holle was gut findet wenn hollen Döner
für gut erklärt meine ich der Mann hat
alle Döner in Deutschland gegessen
gefühlt ich freue mich sehr weil in Köln
endlich ein guten Döner zu haben einen
konstant guten Döner zu haben das ist
ein Traum von mir schauen wir mal vielen
Dank jetzt noch einmal die Chili Cheese
und einmal die scharfe Soße von uns Zi
super vielen vielen Dank dankeön danke
sehr wow das sieht echt nicht schlecht
aus man das sieht wirklich richtig
richtig gut der Reis ist doch nicht ganz
so wie man dachte wir dachten ja dass es
vielleicht einfach weißer nackter Reis
sei ist es nicht das hier drüben muss
der tasty one Döner sein ich sehe schon
direkt ne ich liebe ja Sesam auf dem
Brot das gibt's mittlerweile nicht mehr
immer früher gab es das sowieso halt als
diese fertigen peden benutzt und das
liebe ich ja auch ich mag so diesen
diesen retrodöner so ein
bisschen
es ist endlich soweit Leute wir können
probieren und es ist schon echt eine
schöne Vielfallt die sich hier da bietet
wir haben einmal den facey one Döner
dann meinen persönlichen Döner wie ich
mir konfiguriert habe so wie ich ihn
früher immer gegessen habe mit schicken
mit Knoblauchsoße das hier finde ich
echt sehr interessant für 1,99 we dafür
kriegst du okay ein bisschen günstiger
kriegst du ein Cheeseburger bei Mac ist
das schon heftig mit Dönerfleisch einen
Burger ein bisschen Reis ein paar Pommes
probieren wir den tasty one oder der
sieht wirklich krass aus mit diesen
frittierten Zwiebeln die sehen auch ganz
eindeutig selbstgemacht aus ich probiere
einfach jetzt komm schön dünn ist das
Brot tatsächlich ne also du hast nicht
so ein richtig dicken Fladen ich kann
mir vorstellen dass das so eine pzente
Rolle einnimmt eher im Geschmacksbild
aber so knusprig wie es ist hat man
vielleicht trotzdem die wunschtextur
aber wow diese geschmackskreation also
diese Abstimmung von den socen ist
wirklich verdammt gut und das dönerbrot
mit das also nach dem ersten Bissen muss
ich sagen mit so das niceste was ich
hatte da ist jetzt cocktailsoße drauf
und cheese ne so eine Mischung aus
Cocktail und cheesesoße schau auf dieser
Unterseite ist cheese oben ist Cocktail
aber Bro also ich verstehe warum Holly
den so gefeiert hat ich finde den sehr
sehr gut das kalimfleisch hat ja auch
wirklich eine gute Röstung gehabt bevor
die es abgeschnitten haben da kann man
denke ich aber immer noch mal Pech haben
das würde ich jetzt nicht garantieren
aber am meisten begeistert mich dieses
dieses dönerbrot das hat schon fast so
ein bisschen was von so einem Panino wie
die die bieten ja auch Panini an also so
wenn du so ein chabat oder sowas
Kontaktgrill hast und das schön knusprig
ausgebacken wird so ein Crunch hat
dieses Brot geil also es ist wirklich
was sehr sehr einzigartiges das ist
jetzt kein kein Döner von der Stange
dementsprechend auf jeden Fall wert
ausprobiert zu werden das will ich ganz
schnell probieren dieser tasty one
snackbger bisschen Dönerfleisch
angeröstetes Bann ist bisschen kalt
bisschen hart aber probieren wir das ist
kein Produkt was du machst wenn du dich
für dein Dönerfleisch schämst weil steht
geschmacklich zu 100% im Vordergrund und
es schmeckt wirklich verdammt gut der
Spieß ist einfach lecker finde ich fast
ein bisschen krass also ich hätte
gedacht dass das schwer zu
kommerzialisieren und in so ein Konzept
zu packen ist so weil wirnerläden sind
immer so individuell und so und dass das
so gut funktioniert qualitätstechnisch
ist sehr beeindruckend finde ich ich
probier mal den Reis weil ich muss ehcht
gesagt sagen ich finde es ein bisschen
unnötig also Pommes oder Reis zum Döner
zu bestellen weil für mich ist ein Döner
so ein perfekt abgerundetes Ding du hast
dein Brot deine Kohlenhydrate im Brot du
hast dein Protein du hast bisschen
Gemüse drin und so aber vielleicht
überzeugt mich dieser Reis hier vom
Gegenteil für mich bleibt glaube ich
unnötig für mich wird es immer ein Döner
und Getränk sein ich brauch keine Pommes
und kein Reis dazu aber ich wollte es
mal testen schmeckt aber auf jeden Fall
alles andere als Standard jetzt bin ich
wirklich gespannt und ich erst das
letzte Mal wo du wirklich wow gesagt
hast bei dem Döner war bei ran in Berlin
der hier verspricht alles zu haben was
er haben soll so hätte ich ihn mir
früher gewünscht probieren
wir die Soße ist leider nicht 100% da
das ist eine joghurtkoblauchsoße und
diese Knoblauchsoße die ich so liebe
diese Berliner
Knoblauchsoße ja so eine Mayo
Knoblauchsoße ich w nicht auf den ersten
Bissen mein Finales Urteil geben deshalb
wir probieren ein bisschen dann sage ich
euch meine abschließenden
Gedanken kann dieser Döner das klaffende
Loch in meinem Herzen füllen im nein es
ist einfach ich weiß es nicht diese
joghurtkobl es sind einfach Nuancen und
so eine süßliche Knoblauchsoße ich
bestell mir den Döner ohne Soße dann
gehe ich zu Haus Döner und sag mach mal
bitte Soße drauf dann bin ich da weil
sonst ist alles perfekt das Fleisch ist
perfekt das Brot ist perfekt aber ich
weiß es nicht wenn man wenn es mit der
Jugendliebe nicht so wirklich klappt
muss man sich vielleicht mal neu
umschauen und ich muss euch sagen dieser
tasty one Döner einfach von dem was ich
gelesen habe hätte ich niemals gedacht
dass er mir so unfassbar gut schmecken
würde er schmeckt auch wirklich mir
deutlich besser als meine eigen Kreation
es lohnt sich 100% auszutesten
spannendes interessantes Konzept und wir
gehen jetzt zur nächsten neu Eröffnung
so Freunde wir sind jetzt auf dem Weg
zum nächsten Spot und den wollte ich
schon länger testen da bin ich auch
wirklich sehr gespannt weil ich noch nie
cornogs gegessen habe und Bro wir testen
heute die gehyptesten neue Öffnung das
ist Hype pur ohne Witz ich habe das so
oft auf tiktok gesehen das allererste
Mal von cornogs habe ich aber auf
neotaste gehört und neotaste dürfte den
Foodies unter euch schon ein Begriff
sein kleine Sache schon mal vorab ich
habe ein Special für euch rausgehandelt
mit dem Code Max Taste erhaltet ihr zwei
Monate neotaste Premium umsonst falls
ihr es aber noch nicht kennt hier eine
kurze Erklärung neotaste ist die
Restaurant Entdecker App in der ihr
mittlerweile schon in 19 Städten über
2000 Restaurants entdecken könnt und das
beste ist es kommen täglich neue Städte
und Restaurants dazu in der App findet
ihr wichtige Informationen wie Bilder
Rezension Speisekarten Kontaktdaten oder
Öffnungszeiten hinter mir seht ihr jetzt
schon den Laden wir sind vor cogs und
eines der besten Features in der
neotaste App zeige ich euch jetzt und
zwar kannst du den zwe für ein corndog
Deal aktivieren wenn du Mitglied bei
neotaste t bist diese Deals wie 2 für
ein Hauptgericht 10 € Direktrabatt oder
eine kostenlose vor oder Nachspeise gibt
es nur wenn ihr die neotaste App benutzt
und ihr spart so im Durchschnitt 13 €
pro Restaurant Besuch wir gehen jetzt
gleich einfach rein ich zeig mein Coupon
in der neotaste App und die da drin
wissen sofort bescheid das ganze kostet
den monatlich Küb Modell 4,99 pro Monat
und im jährlichen 3588€ also nur 2,99 €
pro Monat wie bereits gesagt könnt ihr
mit dem Code Max Taste neotaste zwei
Monate lang kostenlos ausprobieren das
empfehle ich euch sehr wir gehen jetzt
rein und gucken mal was wir uns
bestellen ist auf jeden Fall gehipt ja
ich glaube traditionelles penco lass uns
einmal penco und einmal Cornflakes
machen oder ja würde ich auch sagen
hallo wir sind mit neoaste
[Musik]
hier das sind zwei wichtige Apparate
also ohne Witz ich muss jetzt mal sagen
der placementil ist vorbei 6,90 € für
die beiden Dinger ist wirklich ein super
Deal deshalb checken new Taste aus ihr
Können nichts verlieren das ist
kostenlos so probieren wir halp Hype oh
junge Alter das ich würde das gerne mal
auf eine Waage packen also ich glaube
for real das sind 350 400 g das ist
richtig viel du bist danach auch satt
nach ja normal alter das ist fett mit
Fett und Fett beim Kern konnte man
auswählen zwischen einer
rinzwurstfüllung Käsefüllung und
gemischt wir haben uns für gemischt
entschieden das kommt dann in so ein
relativ Zähnen Teig wird ummantelt
frittiert und am Ende mit einer Soße
getoppt super einfaches Produkt
eigentlich trotzdem kriegst du es
eigentlich nirgendwo in Deutschland ich
glaube ich werde mir den Mund verbrennen
aber ich bin bereit es zu tun weil das
sieht einfach lecker aus lassen wir es
uns schmecken das schmeckt obwohl ich
das erst einmal gegessen habe in Amerika
total vertraut das schmeckt so ein
bisschen nach Weihnachtsmark so
frittiert mit Teig und so weißt du wie
ich meine die Soßen oben drauf kennst du
so von der belgischen Pommesbude ich
habe auf Empfehlung vom Chef
Knoblauchsoße und siriraca Mayo genommen
wirklich eine sehr sehr sehr leckere
Kombination kommt die Knoblauchsoße an
deine Kindheitsträume ran sie schmeckt
sehr lecker ja ja also real Talk willst
du einmal reinbeißen halt das mal ganz
kurz BR das ist so schwer das Ding ne
und jetzt beiß einmal ab ist ist das
kulinarisch raffinierteste was ich hier
gegessen habe nein aber es ist so simpel
dass es einfach funktionieren muss und
es schmeckt auch echt lecker also auch
das soll nicht das letzte gewesen sein
heute wir lassen uns unsere corndog
schmecken und dann sehen wir uns zum
dritten Spot bei der bowlmaker Society
ihr seht da hinten schon auch hier
wieder die Hölle los alle drei neue
Öffnung sind wirklich gehyped also ich
habe es nicht nur in Titel geschrieben
sondern an einem ganz normalen Wochentag
ist richtig viel los wir gehen hier rein
Bau Maker Society der Name verrät ein
bisschen hier kann man sich seine
eigenen rahmenbs zusammenstellen und wir
schauen mal welche wir uns machen also
man geht hier links an diesem offenen
Kühlschrank sucht sich raus was man in
seine Rahmen möchte wiegt dann die
Schüssel WT eine Brühe aus und fertig
ist deine B so einfach kann sein ne ja
und ich meine es gibt bestimmt Leute die
Angst haben vor so asiatischen
restaurantkonzepten weil ich denke oh
das mag ich aber bestimmt nicht das mag
ich nicht nur das möchtest stimmt mal
schauen wie viel wir jetzt zahlen müssen
was war die teuerste Rahmen die jemand
hier bestellt hat 33 € 33 € ich hab
schon das ein oder andere Mal se Rahmen
gemacht und du machst ja eigentlich
nicht so super viel an fillings rein 791
ist echt fair hier kann man das später
noch toppen das heißt wir warten jetzt
ab bis unsere Rahmen fertig sind und
dann können wir auch schon probieren
Brühe sieht schon mal vielversprechend
aus aus ernusssoße nehmen wir uns ein
wenig zack libt man ja auch ne wenn man
sowas selbst machen kann ja schön
Lauchzwiebeln dürfen auch nicht fehlen
dann sieht das direkt aber auch schon
aus wie eine h r
Leute ich muss sagen ich bin überrascht
gerade eben noch ein Zuschauer hier
getroffen der gesagt hat dass die Nudeln
häufig zu durch sind das werden wir
natürlich auch testen wir gehen
natürlich auch kritisch an die Sache
hieran es gibt in Köln schon gute Rahmen
muss man sagen also auch bei len die
sich da auch spezialisiert haben und so
ein richtiges Service Konzept haben das
hier ist interessant weil hier kann
jeder das essen was er möchte trotzdem
wird's nicht leicht weil wie gesagt man
findet gute Rahmen in Köln hier haben
wir diese Röllchen Fleischröllchen die
ich vorhin hatte die tauche ich einfach
mal in die Tom jumbrühe du musst jetzt
sagen ob auch schmeckt also die Brühe
ist schon mal echt nicht verkehrt ich
habe vielleicht nicht die beste Wahl
getroffen weil ich Tom jum noch nicht so
häufig gegessen habe und dementsprechend
nicht so perfekt vergleichen kann aber
es schmeckt würzig es schmeckt cremig
ist schon echt gut ich mag es sehr gerne
max war
skeptisch ich sag so wir wollten
eentlich zu einem anderen Laden gehen
weil ich mir dachte so wie gut kann es
sein aber die Brühe ist echt nicht
verkehrt aber so dieser frittierte Tofu
in eine cremige Suppe getungt ist auch
immer geil wir wissen jetzt mittlerweile
wie die Rahmenbedingungen sind das ist
schon mal ein bisschen schlecht wenn das
so in einem Block hier rauskommt oder es
sind auch andere Rahmen einfach ne also
bisschen dünner ne bisschen dünner als
die die man jetzt so von Takumi kennt
und wie es auch bei daikan hier in Köln
gibt aber so wie sie sich anfühlen sind
sie auf jeden Fall nicht zu
weich hab guten bis bisschen schwierig
zu händeln mein Ei was ich mir
reinkonfiguriert habe ist leider kaputt
gegangen also so eine schüsselrahmen ne
so wie ich sie jetzt hier habe kostet in
den zuvorgenannten rahmenraurants 13 €
aufwärts sind nicht die besten Rahmen
die ich in Köln gegessen habe aber für
den Preis sehr sehr gute so Freunde das
war doch ein wunderschöner Tag wir haben
uns mal wieder einen Überblick über die
Kölner restaurantlandschaftterchaffen es
war wunderschön neue Konzepte entdeckt
auf jeden Fall einen kleinen Trend
entdeckt alles ist irgendwie bisschen
instagramable alles ist irgendwie muss
halt so sein heutzutage das ist der Zahn
der Zeit ich bin gespannt welche
Restaurants sich festigen können welche
vielleicht noch besser werden es hat
Spaß gemacht mit Euch wie immer ich
würde sagen wir sehen uns beim nächsten
Video wieder bis dahin ciao ciao